peuple
[Musique]
j'entends vous avez toujours l'air
d'être en vacances c'est curieux savant
curieux pour quoi je parle je n'ai pas
l'impression de travailler
pendant ce temps mais ce que j'aime bien
apprendre la vie comme ça comme hey les
gars c'est du côté des soucis sont là
rien on a le temps de se faire vraiment
de l'humour on vous fait du mouron
pendant pas en tournage c'est tout ao du
don quand je tourne je me fais pas de
souci j'aime bien j'aime bien sa tournée
j'aime bien jouer la comédie rencontre a
cédé encore des vacances on n'arrive pas
à connaître belmondo j'ai lu un article
récemment ou les metteurs en scène qui
vous ont dirigé plusieurs fois
n'arrivais même pas à vous définir est
ce que vous vous étiez vous même si vous
arrivez à belmondo c'est quoi voilà un
message m passage devant les gens qui
définit ce qu'ils disent moi je suis si
moi je fais ça marche et je chante ça
dépend il ya un matin je suis quelque
chose de lendemain matin c'est surtout
sur ses journaliers vous rattache une
bonne humeur mais à des freins mais ça
l'est moins mais il ya de nombreuses
définitions del mondo on dit par exemple
c'est un dur au coeur tendre ces squats
les définitions sur un acteur souvent
ces stars fonctions un peu des rôles
qu'on joue c'est dire si son est en
train de jouer dur et le dur et à la fin
étant grandi welmant dos fait un
dentiste un seul petit voyou en velours
est un voyou et quand j'ai joué mais on
voir un prêtre ben quand j'achetais mon
journal de regarder un peu comme si on
était plus respectueux et là c'est un
film qui sent aussi un bon voyous on va
plutôt tendance à me croyez avoir
regardé comme un voyou je crois que les
gens me ne sait ce qui est bien dans le
métier d'acteur comme vous on
m'identifie beaucoup au rôle d'ailleurs
c'est les acteurs qui jouaient le mail
autrefois je crois que le traite les
gens la sortie pour le battre et ça tant
que les gens auront cette naïveté vers
l'acteur trouve que c'est bien faut pas
se plaindre que les gens s'identifient
au rôle c'est pas grave mais le monde
aussi un jour vous vous rendez compte
que vous contenter d'être belmondo dans
les films non plus d'incarner le
personnage ça serait grave alors oui ce
serait grave ça serait triste surtout
parce que je trouve que le métier
d'acteur c'est très joli et si on joue
son personnage à soi tout le temps c'est
plus drôle ce qui est bien c'est d'être
justement un matin je prends un boucher
lendemain
être un directeur du sinn et le danger
du sida c'est ça c'est que les
producteurs ont tendance à vouloir vous
enfermer dans un film quand on a du
succès dans un jeu on veut toujours voir
facile suis là c'est pour ça que je
lutte un peu contre ça et je veux
revenir à d'autres rôles et j'espère ne
jamais on a toujours tendance à dire un
acteur fait du belmondo du gamin je ne
sais pas mais faut essayer de ne pas le
faire juste un mois j'ai mon ambition
c'est pas de devenir belmondo jouant du
belmondo ça m'amuse pas du tout est ce
que vous pensez vous êtes dans vos
emplois
ces emplois c'est laisser des mots on
dit comme ça aussi ça c'est quand on est
au conservatoire il n'y a pas d'emploi
je crois pour moi un acteur doit pouvoir
toujours enfin tous ensuite me demandait
de jouer roméo je pourrais pas mais il
ya une palette très large on peut
essayer de jouer donc il ya pas un
emploi défini je trouve dommage quand on
dit justement dans les coups on a tort
de dire 110 un acteur vous vous avez un
emploi comics vous avez un emploi de
jeunes premiers c'est ce que ça veut
rien dire mais vous regrettez pas de de
ne pas être un gros comique disant ah
non j'ai pas de regret je suis content
parce que je ne sais pas si un jour
j'avais un rôle de gros gros comique et
j'espère tu pourrais bien en dessous et
on peut dire belmondo maintenant vous
avez du métier non pas ça commence ça
fait 16 ans cheikh tu es quand on a du
métier on dispose des ficelles c'est pas
dangereux oh non parce que je crois que
les ficelles c'est une chose qu'on on
peut avoir au bout de 6 mois donc si on
veut s'en servir c'est pas les acteurs
qui qui servent des ficelles je sais pas
parce qu'ils jouent depuis que ça n'est
exempt beaucoup de métier je pense que
c'est parce qu'il ya pas de tempérament
au départ ou de l art s'est tout de
suite la ficelle c'est comme en boxe
époque series et accroche dès le départ
c'est parce qu'ils en 70 combats qu'ils
accrochent me suis accroché tout c'est
quand on dit quand on parle de belmondo
c'est pour en revenir tout à l'heure on
a honte quand on parlait des définitions
on disait belmondo tout dans les mains
rien dans le cerveau qui secoue 100
français et cdt du propos lui ça
non je crois que ça c'est là aussi cdd
je pense y avait la tête plein jusqu'en
tout à fait normal mais a bien aussi par
les personnages que j'ai joué toute
cette légende j'ai eu des fois des
petits accrochages comme sale on dit
aussi que je me bats ce qu'il faut que
je pense que socialement pas de solution
cherche vraiment sens à ces points c'est
pas mon genre mais je me sers de ma tête
quand il faut s'en servir mais dans
classe touriste vous aviez une réplique
je me rappelle c'était je vais peut-être
pas grand-chose mais j'ai mon gauche oui
voilà c'est ça a lancé martin sirois
redevenir de là parce que mes vieilles
les gens c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure et il adore vous identifier ou
aux personnages et moi là beaucoup de
maisons de journalistes se sont régalés
à écrire ça je sais tout à l'heure je
lisais des trucs quand je les lisais je
les tiens maintenant les gens voient ça
ils doivent se dire c'est vraiment un
minus pas ce que faisait faire des
fougères vous prête même des réponses
que vous ne faites jamais est-ce que
leurs adhérents est ce qu'elle vous
effraie votre légende parce qu'il
légende del mondo nos rejets mais elle
m'effraie pas sommet ferait pas du tout
parce que moi je sais comme je suis et
et finalement je crois que les
spectateurs ils vont venir me voir jouer
si immense parce que j'aime bien me voir
jouer passé mais c'est tout je fais dans
la vie je crois que ça ne regarde pas
tellement et ça leur est égal parce que
moi je sais que j'ai des acteurs pour
qui j'ai une passion on m'aurait dit
dans la ville est complètement idiot ce
m'est égal ou déforment le choix des
acteurs très mauvais et on me dira mais
il est d'une intelligence rare il y
explore dans le texte c'est tant mieux
enfin surtout sur le théâtre je vois pas
tout ça et ce avant lui
jean paul belmondo a commencé cette
semaine le nouveau film de jean becker
tendre voyou cette journée nous l'avons
passé du matin au soir avec lui
y'a pas de tunnel dont il n'y a pas de
long texto nos bonnes trop cruel
damafro faut savoir quand même non et
j'aime pas à prendre avant
d'apprendre juste un bon tour c'est ce
qui fait dire je droit aux anciens free
vous arriver comme ça avec tout et
j'arrive comme ça c'est faux parce que
si jeune si j'apprends pendant huit
jours avant après c'est très mécanique
fait par
manu a justifié non non vous laisse le
reste
vachement que ça va très bien
c'est une scène avec qui la one avec
maria pacôme
des retrouvailles si j'avais joué au
théâtre avec m oscar
bah était dans les tribulations et était
dans les tribulations si au final
camarades
c'est pourquoi même ses cheveux
les
voiliers mais ou perdre plus de temps
c'est pas à prendre le thème cette année
de l'espine c'est ce que les gens
comprennent pas
c'est là où le métier d'acteur est très
difficile notre bon sport mais bien une
cravate c'est tout un honneur c'est là
les ficelles du métier
les personnes pour vous donner la
réplique à pour répéter avant non mais
je repasse donc je vais répéter tout à
l'heure sur le plateau avec maria
est suffisant ou pas refuser
voilà ça va confirmer ma réputation 2010
qui comprend rien
pourquoi détruire les gens
voient là un vous notre fait en tout cas
pas dire minutes mais consciencieux
ahmed de moutons et précisons que c'est
une chemise rose jeudi sera opposé à oui
parce que c'est de la télé n'a pas
encore à leur avantage du cinéma c'est
mon coup leur ancien choix que les gens
préfèrent aller paris cinéma que de
rester devant leur poste de télé
voilà mes appuis je m la lave est
supporter de celle aller manger en
invitant
la baisse
ça change un fonds
va pouvoir frapper les trois coups la
jambe holnon ils nagent pas que c'est
c'est la rentrée
on y va on y va
c'est pas possible si
c'est je suis sorti ce matin j'ai pas le
droit de me lever mais chez moi je
prépare exister faire fox ne vois pas ce
que personne n'a non monsieur moi je moi
je criais ton nom je lui enlève g
ameuter tout service d'infirmières mon
rêve à moi mon chéri mais empêchement
de la faculté pendant une semaine on va
être forcé de
vivre comme frères et soeurs
labèque dur et mata santé avant tout là
ils vont pas de planter deux c'est ce
qu'on va faire tu vas prendre la chambre
moi je touche ici sur le livre non non
non ça je peux pas que tu veux faire une
chute puis interdiction de te lever
demain tu sera servie olic d'un régime
infernal
grillades poissons
tu savais toi que recommander le cas via
un euro et bah c
est pour la boisson je fais rentrer des
eaux minérales oui tu peux tu peux aussi
faire entrer un peu de bordeaux
condition qu'il soit du 1er cru mais un
peu de scotch aussi pour les trucs
vasculaire ce serait plutôt un
médicament ta bouteille dans le buffet
tu vois comme c'est drôle j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une armoire à
pharmacie
à quelle batterie la vie
je te dise maria nous sommes très bien
oui alors nous allons aller au bar
[Musique]